في غضون ذلك عم اضراب شامل حي جبل المكبر
في القدس المحتله حيث دعى الاهالي الى غلق
المحال التجاريه
وتعطيل مظاهر الحياه كافه وياتي الاضراب
واحتجاجا على عمليات الهدم الانتقاميه
للاحتلال في الحي مؤخرا تنفيذا لقرارات
المجلس الامني المصغر في اسرائيل
وما يحيط به وانت تزامنه ايضا مع زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
مريم الاضراب يعمه كافه مناحي الحياه هنا
في حي جبل المكبر بالقدس المحتله الشبان
الفلسطينيون ومنذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
خرجوا الى الشوارع وقاموا بسددها
بالاطارات المطاطيه المشتعله وبالحاويات
في اكثر من موقع كهذا الموقع الذي يوجد
فيه الان في هذا الحي هنالك بعض المناوشات
مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحاول
ابعاد الفلسطينيين عن هذه المواقع
المشتعله الان نشاهد هذه الدوريه العسكريه
التابعه لحرس الحدود التي تصل الى المكان
في محاوله كما يبدو لاعاده فتح هذا الطريق
وهو احد الطرق الرئيسيه في حي جبل المكبر
هذا المشهد همم موجود في كافه المناطق في
حي جبل المكبر الفلسطينيون كما اشرت سدوا
معظم ال- ال- المداخل الديه الى الحي منذ
ساعات الصباح
والحياه هنا معطله بشكل تام كافه المحل
التجاريه متجولنا في الحي قبل ان نصل الى
هنا وبالفعل هنالك التزام بهذا الاضراب
الذي دعا اليه الاهالي احتجاجا على عمليه
الانتقام التي ينفذها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بحق المواطنين الفلسطينيين هنا في المدينه
وتحديدا ما يتعلق بهدم منازل الفلسطينيين
بناء على مقررات المجلس الوزاري المصغر
للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه الذي عقد يوم
السبت الماضي واقر فيما اقر همم تفعيل
سياسه هدم المنازل تحديدا ضد المنازل التي
لم تحظى بترخيصا من بلديه الاحتلال هنالك
حاله من الغضب تعمره حيه جبل المكبر وكافه
احياء همم القدس المحتله التي تشهد بين
الحين والاخر مواجهه مع قوات الاحتلال
الاس ل- اا كل الضواحي عمليا ان بيت حنينا
وشعفات المخيم والحي وكذلك هنا في جبل
المكبر والعيسوي كل هذه الاحياء تشهد في
الايام الماضيه مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهنالك بالفعل حاله من الغضب
الشديد لان الفلسطينيون يعتقدون بان قوات
الاحتلال الان سوف تحاول تجديد الخناق على
هذه الاحياء سوف تحاول الانتقام من
الفلسطينيين في هذه الاحياء تحديدا فيما
يخص عمليه هدم المنازل التوقعات بان همم
عمليه همم عمليات الهدم سوف تتطال على
الاقل همم 14 منزل في القدس المحتله
كسياسه انتقاميه وبشكل سريع في غضون
الايام القليله المقبله وبالفعل نحن
شاهدنا جرافات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهي
تقوم بهدمه همم بعض المنازل والمنشات في
حي جبل المكبر في الايام الاخيره همم طبعا
بعض
عمليات الهدم تصدم
بعقبات ان قانونيه هنالك جهود ايضا من
جانب الاهالي للتصدي لهذه الهجمه
الانتقاميه من خلال همم الفرق
فرق الدفاع والمحامين الذين يتوجهون الى
المحاكم الاسرائيليه في محاوله استصدار
قرارات احترازيه بمنع هذه همم سياسه الهدم
الانتقاميه وشاهدنا بالامس ان الاهالي
نجحوا بالفعل على الاقل في تجميد المؤقت
لهدم لاحد المنازل لكن بالمجمل العام
القدس ما زالت تعيش اجواء متوتره قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منتشره بكثافه شديده
في كافه
المدينه كما اشرنا في السابق الى ان
المفاوض العام للشرطه الاسرائيليه كان دفع
ايضا بوحدات اليمام وهي وحدات التي تعنى
بالمكافحه ما يسمى الارهاب كما ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي دفع في الايام الاخيره
بسريرتين عسكريتين للمساهمه في جهود في
حفظ الامن في اا مدينه القدس المحتله
اعاده عن ذلك نشير الى ان زياره انتوني
بلانكن الذي وصل الى اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه في غضم هذه التصعيد الخطير في
القدس وفي الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله لا
يبدو انه مريم يحمل شيئا جديدا معه فيما
يخص الصراع العربي الفلسطيني وفيما يخص اي
خطه جديده للسلام مع الفلسطينيين لكن يسعى
مع الطرفين الى محاوله تهدئه الاوضاع الى
محاوله خفض حده التصعيد سواء كان ذلك في
القدس المحتله او في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله لكن نحن لا نعرف مريم بالفعل ما
هي الخطوط المتاحه او ما الذي يحمله في
جعبته ليقنع الطرفين في تخفيض حده التوتر
واضح بان اسرائيل والاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله همم ماضيه في سياسه
الاعتقالات والدهم اليوميه وعمليات
الاغتيال المستمره في جنين ونابلس وغيرها
من المناطق في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وهذا
يبقي الباب مواردا على مزيد من التصعيد
وعلى مزيد من العمليات العسكريه وعلى مزيد
ايضا من رد الفعل من جانب
الفلسطينيين لذلك من غير المتوقع ان تحرز
هذه الجوله لانتونوبلنكن اي تقدم على
صعيدي التهدئه وعلى الصعيد ربما المضيق
قدما في اي عمليه تفاضليه ما بين الجانبين
الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني اذا ما عدنا الى
الميدان نحن مازلنا نشاهد مريم همم هذه
القوه العسكريه التابعه لحرس الحدود
الاسرائيلي التي تحاول ان تفتح هذا المدخل
الذي سجده الشبان الفلسطينيون في حي جبل
المكبر بالقدس المحتله حيث يعمه الاضراب
الشامل مناحي الحياه كافه هنالك غضب هنالك
احتجاج شديد من جانب الاهالي على سياسه
هدم همم المنازل التي طالت هذا الحي سوف
نرى في قادم الساعات كيف سوف يتطور هذا
الموقف هنا في الحي نحن همم نشير الى ان
غلق هذا المكان ليس اا هو المكان الوحيد
الذي اغلق بالحجاره والاطارات المطاطيه
المشتعله هنالك عده مواقع في داخل الحي
تشهد همم ربما احتكاكات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وايضا اغلاق للطرق العامه في
داخل الحي وايضا بين الحي واحياء همم
اسرائيليه قريبه من حي جبل المكبر نشير
هنا مريم الى ان القدس المحتله همم تعاني
اشد المعاناه تحديدا هذه الاحياء العربيه
المهمله من جانب بلديه الاحتلال بشكل كامل
هنالك قرارات بهدمه همم الاف همم المنازل
التي لا تحظى بترخيص من بلديه الاحتلال
بعض التقديرات تشير الى ان هنالك نحو
20,000 منزل في القدس المحتله مه ده
بالهدم بسبب عدم حصول الفلسطينيين على
التراخيص الفلسطينيون يقولون بانهم لا
يريدون المخالفه وانهم ليسوا معنيين
بالبناء بدون ترخيص لكن واضح بان همم
سياسه الاحتلال وبلديه الاحتلال تضع كثيرا
من العقبات والعراقيين امام الفلسطينيين
للحصول على هذه
التراخيص وهو ما يدفعهم الى البناء بدون
همم هذه الاجراءات القانونيه همم اللازمه
وهو ما يبقيهم عرضه همم بطبيعه الحال مريم
همم الى هذه السياسه المنهجه في السياره
هذه التصعيد الامني في القدس
المحتله شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرم